foreign
we're going out to K in New Orleans
Louisiana okay okay what's up Kate that
was a terrible what accent was that
dude I just shamed my family what I was
kind of like if Louisville Louisville
and never mind I need to stop listen I'm
sorry k for
badgering the what's up how can I how
can I help
uh thanks for taking my call of course
and embarrassing myself what's up what
an abomination
uh my question is how do I improve the
relationship with my family when some
members are trying to make them choose
between me or them
what'd you do
well I was just fishing there but I
guess you did what'd you do I did I did
so throughout high school and college
I struggled uh with alcohol drug abuse
and relationship issues
um and then about five years ago my
boyfriend at the time who's now my
husband
uh physically hurt me and it was pretty
bad I ended up needing emergency surgery
um what did he do
uh well
drug-induced like psychosis hit me and
broke my arm
my gosh okay
yeah
um so my parents stepped in
I was 21 at the time and they stepped in
and they made me move home put me on
house arrest and sent me to like an
outpatient rehab
um was that a good move
um
yeah I got sober
um really really changed my life
honestly
but
them putting me like on house arrest and
treating me like a child again really
kind of
was not so good
because shortly after I started talking
to my boyfriend again and my dad lost it
and basically cut off all communication
with me and kicked me out
um
and stopped speaking to me
so do you under like so I want to let me
let me I know we're just getting the
story but let me butt in here okay
um
I
like hearing what just transpired I I
both think yeah I'd probably handle it
differently and I one thousand percent
understand
yeah
I'm sweet I'm nobody out there is taking
care of my daughter I'm going all in and
man I went too far I made too many
whatever I'm going all in and then when
I find out my daughter has
like is going back to this guy that put
her in the hospital to beat her up
that's like an unsafe drug using
um
maniac
she's going back like at some point I
can see your father saying I can't have
this
like I I've got to I've got to protect
me and my wife now now we can sit I can
armchair quarterback that and be like
you never give up on your daughter all
those things that I would say but I also
want to say man I have the little
seven-year-old girl and let me tell you
k
foreign
I'd go to the ends of the Earth
right yeah
so here we are
um
your dad says get out you do get out and
then you go right back to abusive
boyfriend
yes okay and then you all decide you
know what
things are already crazy
hold our beer we're gonna get married
yeah so it kind of
it was
it was crazy because I mean he got sober
and clean too and I didn't I ended up
moving in with his parents
um and really both of us kind of like
turned our lives around
okay you didn't cheat on him did you
no okay all right good I thought that's
where we were headed all right good no
no no no all right so what happened what
happened we got married a year later
okay so
it was good and I was kind of had
kind of written off my family because it
just
I mean I had spoken with my dad and he'd
be like well I just kind of had wished
that you would have just failed and
needed to come back to me
and I didn't and it kind of
you know I get his side of it I really
do but
it sounds like a crazy story but it was
just that one time thing that nobody
really understands unless they're living
in it I guess
um but now after we've been married a
couple years my dad sees us
and wants to start talking to us again
so we've been trying to build that
relationship
however I have one Aunt who won't let me
come to any family events or anything if
she or her kids are going to be there so
like this is Christmas this is Father's
day with my dad
and this is anything and it's my dad and
my stepmom really kind of take her side
in it
and I've I just don't know
what to do at this point like I've tried
I've sat with my dad I sat with my
stepmom I've said
I'm sorry let me make amends my husband
and I have sat with them
and I've tried with my aunt and she just
she just won't let me
um
so there's uh I don't know where to go
oh man so
I also can I say can I say one more
thing about your dad before I move on
it would be very odd not not unheard of
but out there a little bit
if there weren't challenges in your
childhood your whole life with being
heard or listened to or connected with
is that fair
uh yeah
when I was a kid and my dad and I just
took how to awful relationship yes
and you've been trying to figure out how
we that can be a whole other call
um I want to honor you too okay there's
a reason your body said hey being high
is better than
what I've got to deal with at home
checking out is safer than this
this guy is safer than this
okay and so I want to honor your body
too trying to take care of you as well
in the middle of a chaotic situation
losing your mom is wild always asking
dad why are you as wild trying to be the
token of his like trying to heal his
depression and all the grief and all
that that's all you've been through a
lot right
yeah yeah
and so now I hear somebody who's gone to
hell and back several times
pretty scarred and beat up but the light
is on and you and this guy man he's
screwed up but it sounds like he has
worked his butt off to get clean and to
make his life right and to never ever
ever put his hands on you again ever
and y'all are making a lie for yourself
and there's some people that want to
hang on to the Past correct
yeah okay
here's what I want you to do I want you
to take uh which hand do you write with
right or left
am I right okay I want you to squeeze it
as tight as you possibly can and hold it
for a count of five
squeeze it super hard one
two three four
five
and let it go let's open it all the way
up
okay that's the feeling
if ant doesn't want to come and it's not
going to come
if par if your dad chooses when it when
it he wants to have a relationship with
you he wants to lean back in
after kicking you out
um after a pretty Rocky rotten childhood
he wants back in great but when it comes
down to it he's gonna side with his
sister
yeah
you have to let that go you can no
longer try to be the person who solves
all your dad's problems you've been
doing that your whole freaking life
right and that means you have to make
peace with your dad would rather make
sure his sister is happy
then like the prodigal's son's father go
running out to meet his daughter
yeah and that is Gonna Hurt Like bloody
hell right
mm-hmm
yeah I'm sorry
my dream is this has a happy ending in
that he is like what am I doing this is
my only daughter I've already lost my
first wife this is my daughter
and he
Sprints down the driveway down the
street and meets you before you even get
home
and right now it sounds like he's
talking to his sister Karen to make sure
she's okay with the arrangements before
right
yeah
I mean is there anything that I do
okay this isn't on you you could you can
reach out
yeah everybody felt like three times I
had a face-to-face meeting with her and
she just screams and left yeah she's she
listen she's acting like a child
not like an adult
even even and I'm not saying the ending
would be the same an adult May sit down
and say listen
I I see that y'all are have made a go of
it I see that y'all got married
I cannot take the risk with my family my
little kids that that guy doesn't show
up here high and hit somebody else and
put him in the hospital again I lived
through that I refused to live through
it again period
I might disagree with that outcome I
might totally agree with that outcome
but that would be an adult way to handle
it
just screaming and hollering yeah yeah
come on she's a seven-year-old
and when a seven-year-old starts doing a
temper tantrum I'm not going to give you
the attention
I'm going to as Jay-Z says brush my
shoulders off I'm gonna walk out
right
the alternative is you are going to
spend another decade
running around
like a squirrel in a backyard trying to
solve all of the discomforts of the
adults in your life and that's just
simply not your job your job is to be an
honorable great wife a good partner
to be a great citizen at some point a
great mother if that's the route y'all
choose to take to continue your sobriety
and your healing to lean into those
relationships that lean back into you
you see what I'm saying
yeah and it's real common for somebody
who loses their mom whose mom dies
whose dad dies
to go to the ends of the Earth to try to
keep the family duct taped and stitched
together
yeah the hard work
yeah feels like what
it feels like I'm the only one that's
really trying to it's let go open your
hands
create the greatest Thanksgiving in
Christmas that may be something you've
never done to sit down with your husband
and do it in June
hey what do we want Christmas not to
look like what do you want to feel like
yeah we wanted to have lots of laughter
and we wanted to have silly gifts and we
want to have old movies
that might mean no families involved
that might mean a couple of friends
because our families don't laugh they're
too serious they get all uptight they
want to complain about the way you're
letting Billy grow his hair out whatever
I think the whole world K is realizing
that life is simply too short
to have it dictated and operated by
other people who will never be satisfied
and I think globally we're all realizing
I don't want you to use me as a way to
make you feel better
yeah and so I appreciate you and I love
you I'm gonna treat you with dignity and
kindness and I'm heading off you have a
great week
and you're gonna have to deal with maybe
you write a letter to her that you will
never send maybe you write a letter to
your dad that you will never sin but you
process this you sit in it for a minute
and then you begin the
could be it's going to be hard but it
could be really fun uh a task of
deciding like what do we want our life
to look like
because we can do anything
Fair yeah it's fair it's just kind of
like I'd still
I don't know I'm I just go don't talk to
them anymore or just like talk to them
on their terms or I think you put one
day on your calendar once a month that
you reach out
okay
and if they say oh you're just gonna not
talk to us anymore you are happy to just
like you would with a high school
boyfriend say uh the phone works both
ways
yeah
and maybe you quit calling you start
writing letters
and you just put it on your calendar I'm
gonna write once a month
okay
and this I'm going to communicate
because this is the only way the
children and adults bodies and clothes
are able to for me to communicate with
them
otherwise our communication becomes a
way for them to lecture us and to
complain to us and to try to solve all
of our problems and to let us know what
they think of our decision that's cool
man
and I will say this
you said it's it's
um
one-time thing and you can only know it
if you were living in it
I want to challenge that
the one thing I do know is that when I'm
emotional when I'm really head over
heels for somebody or something or I'm
really raged out or I'm terrified and
scared because somebody's hurting me or
trying to hurt me
I know that my body goes directly into
fight or flight there's also fighter
fighter freeze and there's also a less
common less talked about fight flight
freeze or Fawn when I'm gonna nuzzle up
to the person that keeps hurting me
in an attempt to try to woo them and to
stop hurting me
and people who suffer from abuse often
say things like
you just don't understand and it's just
one time
and it's kind of like when the way
Holyfield beat Tyson was he kept getting
real close real real close and it feels
insane except that people can't fully
extend a punch when you're one inch away
from them that's the Fawn I'm just gonna
I'm gonna love you
and I know that when I get emotional I
have to have people in my life that I
trust that I Outsource that to I gotta
have this truck I gotta have this truck
dude don't buy a truck you idiot
okay thanks
my wife's the worst my wife dude your
wife's pretty awesome you're actually
the right now
you gotta have other people in your life
speak into it and if somebody is willing
to
burn your relationship down or to save
your life when all the smoke and fog
clear sometimes it's good to Exhale and
say
thank you
I didn't like how that felt or how you
did that but thank you
this is a messy messy messy situation
okay I want you to always go back to you
and your husband saying hey what do we
want our life to look like how do we
want our life to feel what do we want
what do we want this thing to look like
in three to five years and most
importantly what of this can we control
and let's set off down that road
together
and brush those shoulders off